my name is George Burgess I serve as
director of the Florida program shark
research if you see a shark while in the
water of course the first thing to do is
to get out if you can and that seems
obvious to to most people but surfers in
particular who swim a lot in the water
and see sharks oftentimes don't worry
about it because they've been with them
before and then sometimes they get this
if sharks actually coming at you and
looks like it's going to make contact
with you the nose is a sensitive spot if
you can bop it on the nose with your
fist it likely will veer away and once
again you hopefully will have enough
time to get out of the water finally if
the in fact a shark has got you in its
jaws the eyes and the gill slits the the
five openings behind the the eyes are
very sensitive and stick your fingers in
there clawed them and some people that
have been bit have had success in
getting them to open their mouths when
you poked at their eye the odds of being
attacked actually have never been lower
than they are right now simply because
we're putting so many people in the
water that it's just like having an
extra lottery tickets thrown into the
pools so individually our odds of being
attacked have never been lower
[Music]